i was just talking to my boy i think  there's aliens here  i think they do that i know i believe in  mermaids for some mermaids they really  well i think aliens are in the ocean  aliens this i get they're saying say  anything really i think memory is real i  don't care what woman well is there some  sort of uh thing you saw that made you  did you see your mermaid no i just i  don't know sun in my mind it like  certain [ __ ] be in my mind  did i believe would you smash a mermaid  if she find the one i see on that movie  that i watch  i'll definitely go  you throw a mermaid today [ __ ] yeah i  put that [ __ ] on  that one i see i ain't never seen that  move with the mermaid in it i saw it  like in the 80s 90s the old movie  was fine what was it called splash right  something yeah yeah yeah you wouldn't  even i mean i mean listen i'm married  but hypothetically if my wife was a  mermaid i'd [ __ ] her  i [ __ ] a wife version of a mermaid